well brad i wish we were meeting on
different circumstances i was rooting
for you you were my number one but it's
still a huge
honor to be part of this history making
season of survivor
i know wow
thank you yeah no i appreciate that
that's fantastic
i know it's still pretty fresh but how
are you feeling today
oh you know that was a very that episode
last night was amazing it it's a little
bit you know
bittersweet ripping the band-aid off it
it felt good yes i already knew how is
it gonna end obviously i've kind of
accepted that so last night actually was
pretty healthy
and you had so many advantages last
night what was going through your mind
when you picked up that advantage after
you tried to build the fire
oh man it just
all the realization started coming to me
that oh this this is happening man this
is what you picture when you're playing
this game and all of a sudden it's
happening and this is working and and
the game i was playing was kind of a run
and gun and forward and i knew that i
would need advantages to go further in
this game that's what i was relying on i
was trying to build alliances trying to
do that but i knew that so when i found
that i'm like oh yeah here we go boy
game on
and you also found the idol
jd and everyone were running around
trying to find it too so
were you kind of laughing inside knowing
that they were searching frantically and
you had it
i love that right because you know an
idol hunt is kind of like hunting for a
big game right when you're out hunting
for
but game you you gotta put yourself in
that position so you put your mind where
would jeff hide an idol and that's what
i'm i'm wrestling with i'm not just
running through the forest looking for
stuff i'm like what i'm thinking too and
you usually look for a big tree a big
something you know that stands out well
there was this group of trees that kind
of had funky roots that i'm like oh
that's a neat little area and i went
back to that area two or three times
like it's got to be right and this just
feels right just that that feeling and
so now it really cracked me up when
they're running around chickens with
their heads cut off and i'm i'm just
finding it that felt very very good
you revealed to fan that you had two
advantages and she instantly
wanted to target you do you regret
telling her
great question right i've thought
through this a million times
no the short answer is i don't regret
and the reason is
i was in trouble i had all my powers
stripped i had calculated that risk laid
on my bed for an hour
going
should i shouldn't i jeannie knew i had
genie but i knew i needed more i had no
vote right and so i'm like i need to buy
shan's alliance and i wanted to show her
hey shan i've got all these tools we can
use these these are for us let's you me
and jeannie crush this thing with this
kind of power and i was sincere in it
and i don't regret it all my friends at
the watch party were like what are you
doing don't no don't and i'm like no i
calculated it i don't regret it but
yeah good question
that's fair enough she was a friend she
was an ally you felt safe
but did you feel safe going into tribal
council knowing that you didn't have a
vote
no i felt very vulnerable and and i i
knew my heart was opened up to shan i
knew she was the linchpin that could
change everything and so we tried to put
it on jd
and i could tell jd wasn't nervous he
wasn't blowing up tribal he wasn't
freaking out which he would have been
doing he's a good enough read of people
that he'd known and so i'm getting
nervous right i'm like oh this is
trouble but what can i do the monsters
stripped me of my powers and i'm in
trouble and i just like
it was slow motion my mind just couldn't
get wrapped around what can i do what
can i do and and i don't know maybe
maybe you guys can lend some advice
right because it's like ah man i i
didn't know what to do
well you kept your cool which was good
to see and i feel like you kept your
cool throat this whole your whole time
on survivor how were you able to do that
in such high stakes
question because you know
when you're on that island and you're
you're playing your heart right and yes
you can you can you can tone it down
don't become a threat bring it back you
know and i'm like i could play a
different way that's not me
and i could still get voted out you
could still lose if you played the
perfect game this game is so
dangerous in that way that
just be yourself and that's my advice to
future players like hey just you won't
have any regrets if you play from your
heart and you hit it and that's what i
did that that was my heart out there
that was no pretending that was not yes
i made mistakes those mistakes were from
the heart learn from your mistakes and
move on and that's who i am
that is great advice for future players
when you went to the island with sydney
and tiffany
was it hard to trust them when you were
deciding for the steel to vote or the
tarp or was it just get me off this
island so i can sneak back
yes so actually no because maybe my
fault is that i treat people how i want
to be treated and i trust people very
quickly and so when i went out there i
look at sydney i look at tiffany two
very strong ladies
and i'm like wow i these are great these
are people i i can work with and so
there was no question plus i had the
ferris bueller body on the beach and so
i'm like i can sit here all night to
work this out they were nervous they're
like we gotta get back if we get caught
we're in trouble i'm like no i'm good
and so i was coming from a very good
place
will you ever look at broccoli and
butterflies the same after this
experience
my my friends are brian buying me
broccoli heads i'm like oh man they're
like hey brad how's the uh uh how's the
small branches of little broccoli trees
i'm like oh yeah no i butchered it i get
it all
never the same
did you think it was weird when xander
first said that butterfly thing were you
like this is just so out of normal
he totally sold it right because you're
in front of jeff and you kind of want to
impress jeff with a big statement and so
he said that i'm like that guy is crazy
he's losing what but he totally sold it
i had no idea that the game was making
him do that until i found the my
advantage i'm like oh that's why he said
it now i gotta pull this off oh
this is a little different
did you think you over thought what you
said
i i totally did right i've put too much
effort in setting it up in my
nervousness of oh i gotta sell this and
so when it came time to say it it was
gone and i'm like oh that's a that's a
horrible feeling to be in front of jeff
and your contestants and your mind is
blank i mean could you see it it was
blank it was not there it was so good
though i feel like that's an iconic
moment you could just see you being like
trying to get the broccoli out perfectly
[Music]
i'm a little afraid that's gonna be my
my
my forever survivor legend yeah how
important is an alliance in staying in
survivor
yes it's all about that alliance and i
knew that i had that with genie okay i'm
running and gunning i'm looking for
idols i'm doing it but in the end i knew
i had to build a strong alliance and
that was my goal going in i wanted to
build alliances that would last a
lifetime you know the rider dies that's
the kind of guy i am and that's what i
wanted and and maybe to a flaw because i
i globbed down a little too quick i
grabbed on to jd i'm like yeah this is
my guy and clearly he wasn't he dogged
me that first first vote and so then
it's like well shan now shan is solid
she's she's golden she touched me on an
emotional and a spiritual level and i'm
like oh shan's legit we really connected
out there and
we could have crushed it her genie and i
i'm like oh this is perfect i thought we
had it
this was the hardest season of survivor
so far
what was the hardest part for you
oh without a question when we lost that
first immunity challenge and we go back
to camp and you got four hours to
scramble to find somebody
that was the worst day of my life katie
that was horrible to to look around and
yes i made a huge blunder and saying
sarah or sham they're the ones
i should have kept my mouth shut but i
could not lie i could not look at sarah
look her in those brown eyes and say no
it's not going to be you tonight i
couldn't do it i couldn't do it and that
i it tore my guts i did not sleep good
that night i i felt horrible that was
the toughest thing by far that kind of
leads me into my next question i felt
like you had a great game and i feel
like you could have went all the way but
if you could change anything about your
game play is there anything that you
would go back and change
yes totally so first of all i'd have
been a little more flexible i had
i i wanted ricardo in that first one and
i'm like well sarah seems to be in with
ricard let's hit sarah you know first
and i kind of stuck to that and when
things were kind of changing to jd and i
think they could have changed the jd
i think i should have went with the flow
a little bit more i shouldn't have been
quite trying to drive the bus and just
just riding on that bus a little bit
more um
no that's probably a little more of that
paranoia a little bit less trusting i
mean it's who i am i can't get through
that but it pays a little bit to go is
shane doing that with everybody or just
me you know and so uh there's some
things that have changed
who do you think is on the chopping
block next
[Laughter]
oh i can't say here i'm afraid i'll i'll
leak a little too much
okay fair enough so based on what you've
seen when you were on the island who do
you want to win
so
great uh man
you you see these people and you see
them playing i love genie genie's heart
is solid gold and i mean she she works
at the supermarket she just she has this
uh you love genie she's emotional she's
kicking that bench and she's letting out
her war whoop you know i love genie it
would be amazing to see jeannie just
crush this thing
and personal feelings aside who do you
think deserves to win from a gameplay
standpoint
yeah
it's this cast is amazing from the
gameplay they know their thing they it's
oh man these 20 year olds are amazing
the young players they know it so
oh i i don't think i'll go any deeper
than that but i'm gonna say really man
maybe maybe every one of them deserve it
that's a really nice answer
and did this experience teach you
anything about yourself
they ask you that right when you're
getting off what'd you learn about and
i'm like i don't know
but just in talking to my family last
night
i said you know what i learned is
life is precious
and you got to it's okay to be
vulnerable and to share
some of your heart and let people know
you know last night i went to a viewing
party and i knew i was getting voted off
right and i kind of wanted to just stay
in my own little home with my little
family and watch it but i'm i told the
the viewing party i said listen i wanted
to be here tonight because you people
are the ones that i wanted to share this
with and i feel comfortable with and
that kind of openness i'm not used to i
think survivor has opened that up to to
appreciate the people you got and to let
them know more importantly let them know
that hey we got something special here
and uh let him know that that's what
it's really taught me you deserve to be
celebrated so i'm glad you went to that
viewing party
what was your experience like like
getting away from the craziness in the
world right now and being on a beach
meeting jeff was it
like kind of distracting from everything
going on
it was totally you know
kovitz crazy and i'm on a ranch i still
feed the cows whether you got covered or
not so so i am totally
less affected than anybody on that
island i truly believe
and and there's some people that really
went through some stuff right and so but
for me
it was a chance to get away from a ranch
that i i give my life to this ranch and
so it was great for me to step away from
this let my people who are on the ranch
kind of have the freedom to run it and
give me the freedom to get away my wife
is like hey you go play your game and it
was just a good reset button you know
i'm 50 years old been here my whole life
and it was a good time to reflect a lot
of journaling a lot of just a good time
to reflect on where you're at and what
you're doing here
sounds like a nice refresher and i don't
know if you saw twitter last night but
everyone was going crazy when you went
home
you are a fan favorite do you have a
message you want to share with your fans
uh
katie that is the hidden bonus that i
didn't see in this whole thing you know
what i mean i walked in the gym at a
volleyball uh high school volleyball uh
match the other day a couple a week ago
in the student section the rowdy student
section brad ray survived and you're
just like dude this is so cool the fans
and and them loving you i mean you see
some bad things on on some social media
and you're like oh social media i'm not
gonna but when they reach out to you and
they tell you oh dude we need more brad
brad's king and ah that hits you it's
like oh it was all worth it for that
right there i love it fans you're
awesome right apply for this game
because it it it affects you on a whole
different level it takes you outside of
that bubble i'm a fan
of getting outside your bubble living on
the edge so you saw it on i'm just on
the thing cbs casting dude apply it
could be you right it'd change your life
you